this is my machine and for some reason
it's learning
what's up code squad if you're new here
welcome to the squad and if not welcome
back my name is kylie ying and today i'm
going to be talking about machine
learning more specifically we'll dive
into supervised learning and then we'll
learn how to use tensorflow to create a
neural net and then use a neural net for
some text classification
sound exciting let's get started
all right jumping straight into things
the first thing that we're going to do
is go to
colab.research.google.com
and it'll pull up a page like this
you're going to click new notebook this
is going to create a new notebook and
let's retitle this to free code camp
tutorial
okay it doesn't really matter you know
what you actually
rename it to as long as you have a
notebook open and
just in case you know you have some
future notebooks that's why you want to
rename all of them
so the typical libraries that i'll
import when i usually start a computer
data science project
are
numpy so
import numpy as np
pandas import pandas as pd
and then import
matplotlib
okay so because i'm going to be using
tensorflow in this video i'm also going
to import
tensorflow
as tf
and then import tensorflow
hub as hub
okay
now if you click shift enter it'll run
this cell
another thing that you can do is click
this little play button over here that
will also run the cell
so
cool
yeah if we click that that runs the cell
as well
all right so the first thing that we're
going to need to do before we can
actually do any data analysis is upload
a data file
so this little folder over here this is
where we manage our data or sorry this
is where we manage our files
and
i'm just going to drag and drop the csv
file the link is in the description
below
into here
so click ok
and you'll see that this is currently
being uploaded
sweet
might take a while because this is
a pretty big data set
we can wait until this yellow
thing goes all the way around
all right so
pause
all right sweet now wine reviews.csv has
uploaded to this folder which means that
we have access to it in this notebook
now so now what we can actually do is
import that csv file as a data frame
using pandas which is this library here
that we imported
so what i'm going to do is say df equals
pd.readcsv
so this is just a command that lets us
read a csv file
and i'm going to type in winereviews.csv
and then also i'm going to
use certain columns so if we actually
took a look at this
uh
data frame here we can call
df.head
we see that we have this like unnamed
column over here that contains a bunch
of
like indices and we don't really want
that so what i'm going to do is say use
columns
give a list of the columns that i want
so i want maybe the country
the description
[Music]
the points
the price
and you know i don't really care about
some of these things like the twitter
handle
i think the variety might be cool to
check out
maybe the winery
all right so
let's
run that and then now take another look
at the data set so now in our data set
we have the country the description the
points the price
the variety and the winery something
that i think would be really cool is to
see if we can try to guess or ballpark
you know whether something falls on the
lower end of the point spectrum or the
higher end of the point spectrum given
the description that we have here
so
the first thing that we do see also is
that we have a few none type values in
our data frame that's what this here
stands for it means there's no value
recorded there
so
let's just focus on these two columns
actually the description and the points
because i think that's what we'll try to
like align we're gonna use a description
to predict the points
something that we can do is a command
called drop nah
don't know if that's you know the right
way to say it but in my head that's what
i say
and we can say subset which means that
you know in a subset of these
columns that's where we're going to try
to drop the pr like the the nand column
so here
i'm going gonna say description
and then points
run that
okay so
don't even know if this has changed
okay i mean we still see this because we
didn't drop anything in that column
because it doesn't really matter to us
let's just quickly see let's plot like
the points column to see the
distribution of the points so we can use
matplotlib for that
so let's do plt.hist
so this is going to be a histogram which
shows the distribution of values
um because it's only a one-dimensional
variable
so
let's do df dot points which calls like
this points column
and let's just say bins equals 20.
now if we do plt.show this should
display our plot
all right i didn't include the title and
the axes because this is kind of just
for us to
quickly look at it if you were to
actually plot
you know this as
some sort if you were to if you wanted
to actually plot this for other people
to view you might want to say plt.title
is know points histogram
and the plt label
the y label so that label for the y axis
would be
you know n the number of values that lie
in each bin
and then the x label i would say
uh
it would be the point
so if we see something like this tada
there is our plot this is our
distribution of points so we see that it
seems like it's on a range from 80 to
100
which means that
let's try to classify these reviews as
below
90 and then above 90. so we're splitting
this into two different categories low
which is over here and high which is
over here
now before
we proceed with the rest of this
tutorial
we're going to learn a little bit about
machine learning because you can't
really just dive into the code without
understanding
what's going on or at least having you
know a vague sense of what's going on
which is what i'm going to try to teach
in this video so let's hop over to some
more
theoretical aspects of machine learning
so first let's talk about what is
machine learning
well machine learning is a subdomain of
computer science that focuses on
algorithms which help a computer learn
from data without explicit programming
for example let's say i had a bunch of
sports articles and a bunch of recipes
explicit programming would be if i told
the computer hey look for these specific
words such as
goal
or player or ball
in this text and if it has any of those
words then it's a sports article
on the other hand if it has flour sugar
oil eggs then it's a recipe
that would be explicit programming but
in machine learning what the goal is i
instead provide the computer with some
sort of algorithm for the computer to be
able to decide for itself hey these are
words associated with the sports article
and these are words associated with a
recipe
sound cool
it is so stay tuned
now these days we've heard a lot of
words kind of you know being thrown out
there such as artificial intelligence
machine learning data science cloud
blockchain crypto et cetera et cetera et
cetera
now we won't talk about the cloud or
crypto or blockchain
but let's kind of talk about ai
versus ml versus data science and what
the difference between all of these is
so artificial intelligence is an area of
computer science where the goal is to
actually enable computers and machines
to perform human-like tasks and to
simulate human behavior
now machine learning is a subset of ai
that tries to solve a specific problem
and make predictions using data
now data science is a field that
actually attempts to
find patterns and draw insights from the
data and you know data scientists might
actually use some sort of machine
learning techniques while they're doing
this
and the kind of common theme is that all
of these overlap a little bit and all of
them might use machine learning
so we'll be focusing on machine learning
there are a few different types of
machine learning so the first one is
supervised learning which uses labeled
inputs
meaning that the input has a
corresponding output label to train
models and to learn outputs
so for example let's say i have these
pictures of some animals so we have a
cat a dog and a lizard
well in supervised learning we would
also have access to these labels so we
would know that this picture is
associated with a cat
this picture is associated with a dog
and this picture is associated with a
lizard
and now because we have all of these
input output pairings we can stick this
data into a model and hope that the
model is able to
then generalize to other future pictures
of cats or dogs or lizards and correctly
classify them
now there's also such thing as
unsupervised learning and in this case
it uses unlabeled data in order to learn
certain patterns that might be hiding
inside the data
so let's go back to our pictures of our
animals
and now we might have multiple pictures
of cats multiple pictures of dogs
multiple pictures of lizards
and also just a quick note that we would
also have these in supervised learning
but all of these would have
the cat label the dog label and the
lizard label associated with them
but okay now going back to supervised
learning we have all these pictures
and what our algorithm is going to want
to do it wants to learn hey these are
all something you know of group a
because they're all similar in some way
these are all group b
and these are all group c
and it basically tries to learn this
inherent structure or pattern within the
things that you know we're feeding it
finally there's reinforcement learning
so in reinforcement learning there's an
agent that's learning in an interactive
environment and it's learning based off
of rewards and penalties
so let's think about a pet
for example
and every single time our pet does
something that we want it to so for
example some sort of trick we give it a
treat
such as in this picture
now
if you know if our pet does something
that we don't want it to for example pee
on our flowers
then we might scold the pet and the pet
would then
like the pet would then start learning
okay
you know it's good when i do this trick
and it's bad when i pee on the flowers
this is kind of what reinforcement
learning is except instead of your pet
it's a computer or i guess an agent
that's being stimulated by your computer
now in this specific video we're just
going to be focusing on supervised
learning so that's using these labeled
input and output pairings in order to
make future predictions
okay so let's talk about supervised
learning
so this is kind of what our machine
learning model is we have a series of
inputs that we're feeding into some
model and then this model is generating
some sort of output or prediction
and the coolest part is that this model
we're as we as programmers are not
really telling this model any specifics
we're not explicitly programming
anything
rather this model
our computer is trying to learn patterns
amongst you know these input this input
data in order to come up with this
prediction
so
a list of inputs such as the ones here
this is what we call a feature vector
we'll talk about that in some more
detail later
so let's quickly talk about the
different types of features or inputs
that we might be able to feed our model
so the first type is qualitative data
and this means it's categorical
which means that there are finite
numbers of categories or groups
so one common example is actually gender
and i know that this might seem a little
bit outdated but
please bear with me because i just want
to get the point of a qualitative
feature across
so here in this picture we see that
there is a girl and a boy so let's take
these two different groups first you
might notice that there's not exactly a
number associated with being a girl or
being a boy
so that's the nature of qualitative data
if it doesn't have some sort of number
associated with it it's probably
qualitative
now let's take a look over here there's
different types of flags like maybe
these represent you know your
nationality might be a qualitative
feature qualitative features don't have
to necessarily be exclusive
but they just don't have a number
associated with it and they belong in
groups so you might have us you might
have canada you might have mexico et
cetera et cetera
these two specific qualitative features
are known as
nominal data in other words they don't
have any inherent ordering in it
now our computers don't really
understand
like labels or english too well
right our computers are really really
good at understanding numbers so how in
the world do we convey this
in numbers well we use something called
one hot encoding so
suppose we have you know a
vector that represents these four
different nationalities usa india canada
and france
what we're going to do
is we're going to market with a 1 if
that category applies to you and 0 if it
doesn't
so for somebody who has us nationality
your vector might look like 1 0 0 0. for
india it might be 0 one zero zero
canada zero zero one zero and france
zero zero zero one
so that's one hot encoding it turns
these different groups into a vector
and
i guess switches on that category with a
one
if that category applies and zero if it
doesn't
now there are also other types of
qualitative features so something like
age even though a number might be
associated with it if we take different
groupings of age so for example baby
kid
gen z
young adult
boomer
etc etc
if we take these different categories
then this actually becomes a qualitative
data set because you can assign one of
these categories to somebody and it
doesn't necessarily map to
a specific number
another example of categorical data
might be a rating system of bad to good
and this is what we call ordinal data so
even though it's qualitative it has some
sort of inherent ordering to it so hence
the name ordinal data
now in order to encode this into numbers
we might just use a system like one two
three four five
quick note the reason why we use one hot
encoding if for our nationalities but we
can use one two three four five
for ordinal data
is because
let's think about things this way our
computer knows that two is closer to one
than five right and in a case like this
it makes sense because two is slightly
less worse than one whereas five is
actually really good so of course two
should be closer to one than five
but if we go back to our nationality
example it doesn't really make sense to
say you know to rate usa one india to
canada three and france four because we
could also switch around these labels
and
they would still be distinct groups and
they're just different it's not like one
of them is closer to the other than
something else
they're just different i mean i guess it
depends on the context but
if we're talking nationality they're
just different right so you can't
necessarily say two which i think was i
assigned to india is closer to one usa
than france which is four
like a computer would think that but
just thinking about it logically that
wouldn't really make sense so that's the
real difference between these two types
of qualitative data sets is how you want
to encode them for your computer
when we're talking about features we
also have quantitative features and
quantitative features are numerical
valued inputs and so this could be
discrete and it could also be continuous
so for example if i wanted to
measure the size of my desk that would
be a quantitative variable
if i wanted to
tell how hot you know what the
temperature of
this fire was that's also another
quantitative variable
another type of quantity and these two
are both continuous variables
now let's say that i'm hunting for
easter eggs and
this is how many easter eggs i collect
in my basket
it probably doesn't make too much sense
to say you know i have 7.5 but rather i
have seven that that would make sense or
eight you know somebody else might have
two which means that i won but you know
aside from that
this is something that would be a
discrete quantitative variable because
we do have it's it's not continuous
right there are discrete values integers
positive integers
that would be able to describe this data
set over here this is continuous and
over here this is discrete
those features those are the different
types of inputs that we might be able to
feed into our model
what about the different types of
predictions that we can actually make
with the model
so there are a few different tasks that
you know we have in supervised learning
so there's classification which means
that we're predicting discrete classes
for example let's say we have a bunch of
pictures of food
so
you know here we have a hot dog we have
a pizza and we have an ice cream cone an
example of classification might be
okay well this gets mapped to a hot dog
label and this gets mapped to pizza and
this gets mapped to ice cream and if we
have any additional photos of one of
these we want to map them to one of
these three classes
this is known as multi-class
classification because we have a bunch
of different classes
that we're trying to map it to so hence
the name multi-class
now
what if instead of hot dog pizza and ice
cream we had another model that just
told us whether or not something was a
hot dog so this over here is a hot dog
and these over here are simply
not hot dogs
well this is known as binary
classification because there's only two
hence binary
it's ready
please god what would you say
if i told you there is an app on the
mind we're past that part just demo it
okay
let's start with a hot dog
oh [ __ ]
my beautiful little adriatic friend i'm
going to buy you the palapa of your life
we will have 12 posts braided palm
leaves
you'll never feel exposed again i'm
gonna be rich
[ __ ] you guilfoyle do pizza let's do
pizza yeah
hey zach
not hot dog
wait what the [ __ ] huh
that's that's it it only does hot dogs
no and a nah hot dog
now let's talk about some other examples
of classification to kind of really
drill this down for you
other types of binary classification
might be
positive or negative so if we have
restaurant reviews positive or negative
two different categories
something else might be pictures of cats
versus pictures of dogs
cool cats and dogs
and then maybe we have a bunch of emails
and we're trying to create a spam filter
one another example of binary
classification might be spam or not spam
now what about multi-class
classification
so going back to our first example of
the cats and dogs
well we also had a lizard you know you
might also have a dolphin so different
types of animals that might be something
that falls under multi-class
classification
another example might be different types
of fruits so orange apple and pear
another example might be different types
of plant species but here basically you
have different types of classes and you
have multiple of them
more than two
all right there's also
something known as regression and in
regression what we're trying to do is
predict continuous values
so one example of regression might be
you know this is the price of ethereum
and we want to predict what the price
will be at tomorrow
well there are so many different values
that we can predict for that and they
don't necessarily fall under classes
like classes just doesn't intuitively
make sense instead it's just a number
right it's a continuous number so that's
an example of regression
or it might be what is the temperature
going to be tomorrow that's another
example of regression
might be what is the value of this house
given you know how many stores it has
how many garages it has what is its zip
code et cetera et cetera
okay
so now that we've talked about our
inputs now that we talked about that
now that we've talked about our inputs
and now that we've talked about our
outputs that's pretty
that's pretty much you know machine
learning in a nutshell
except for the model so let's talk about
the model
okay so before i dive into specifics
about a model
let's briefly discuss
how do we actually make this model learn
and how can we tell whether or not
it's actually learning
we'll actually use this data set in a
real example but here let's just briefly
talk about what this represents
so this data set comes from a certain
group of people and this outcome is
whether or not they have diabetes and
now all these other numbers over here
these are metrics of you know how many
pregnancies they've had what their
glucose numbers are like what their
blood pressure is like and so on
so we can see that all of these are
actually quantitative variables you know
they might be
discrete or they might be continuous
but
they are
quantitative variables
okay so each row in this data set
represents a different sample in the
data so in other words each row
represents one person in our data set
now each column is a different feature
that we can feed into our data set and
by feature i just i literally just mean
like the different columns so this one
here is blood pressure this one here is
number of pregnancies this one here is
insulin numbers and so on
except for this one over here this one
is actually the output label that
we want our model to be able to
recognize
now these values that we actually plug
into the model again this is what we
would call our feature vector
and this this is the target for that
feature vector so this is the output
that we were trying to predict
this over here this is known as the
features matrix which we call big x and
all these outcomes together we call this
the labels or the targets vector y
let's kind of abstract this to a piece
of chocolate or a chocolate bar like
this
and you know we have all the numbers
that represent our x matrix over here
and the values our outputs y our target
sorry over here
now
each of these features so this this is
our feature vector we're plugging this
into the model the model is making some
sort of prediction
and then we're actually comparing this
to our target in our data set
and then whatever difference here we use
that for training because hey if we're
really far off we can tell our model and
be like hey can you make this closer and
if we're really close then
we tell our model hey keep doing that
that's really good
okay so this is our entire bar of
chocolate so let's say this and this bar
here represents all the data that we
have access to
do we want to feed this entire thing
into our model and use that to train our
model
i mean you might think okay the more
data the better right like if i'm on if
i'm trying to look for a restaurant i'd
rather have a thousand reviews than
10. but when we're using but when we're
building a model we don't want to use
all of our data in fact we want to split
up our data because we want some sort of
metric to see how our model will
generalize
so we split up our chocolate bar into
the training data set
the validation data set and the testing
data set
our training data set is what we're
going to feed into our model and you
know this might give us an output
we again we check it against the real
output and we
find something called the loss which
we'll talk about in a second but you can
think of the loss as a measure of how
far off we are so how far off are we put
that into a number value and then feed
that back into the model and that's
where we're making adjustments this
process is called training
now we also have this validation set
so this validation set we also feed into
the model and then we can actually
assess the loss
on this validation set because again we
have the real answer and we have this
prediction and we can see how far off we
are
but this validation set is actually used
as kind of more of a reality check
during or after the training to ensure
that our model can handle unseen data
because remember up until this point our
model is only being trained
with our training set data
okay so for example if i have a bunch of
different models
and
all of these are my validation data sets
and these are the predictions well okay
this loss over here is kind of high this
one's a little bit closer but look this
one is the lowest we want to actually
decrease the difference between our
prediction and our true target
and so another use case for the
validation data set is to actually say
okay well model c seems to perform the
best on unseen data so let's take model
c now once we've selected model c
then we can actually go back and use our
test set which again is unseen data
and we plug that into model c see how it
performs and then we can use that metric
compared to you know our our targets
as a final reported performance
this test set is used to kind of check
how generalizable the final model is
okay
so i kind of touched on you know
something called a loss function
but
what exactly does that mean and what
exactly
how do we how do we quantify how
different things are
well
this would probably give us a higher
loss
than this right like we would we would
want that too because it's a little bit
further off
and something like that should be a lot
further off which means that our loss
function
the value output from the loss function
should be a lot higher than the previous
two that we just saw
okay so there are a few different types
of loss functions so let's put our
mindset in like in terms of regression
for a second so we're trying to predict
a value that's on a continuous scale so
this might be
uh the temperature tomorrow right
now
if we have a bunch of different cities
that we're trying to predict then we
have a bunch of different points right
so this here y real this is the actual
value that we found in our data set and
why predicted this is a value that our
model has output so what we're trying to
do is we're trying to find the
difference between these two values and
then use the absolute value of that
and then add all of these up you know
for every single point in our data set
so all the different cities
in order to calculate the loss so in
other words what we're doing is we're
literally just comparing hey for every
single city how different is our
predicted value and the real value
and then sum up all of those values
so
as you can see you know this is
basically just an absolute value
function so that's what l1 loss is
now if we're really close if our
predictions are really good then you can
see how this loss becomes really small
and if our values are really far off
well that becomes pretty large right
there's also another type of loss called
l2 loss which is the same idea but
instead of using the absolute value
function we square everything
so this is also known as mean squared
error which you might have heard of
basically here instead of summing up all
the differences we actually square all
the differences and then we sum those up
so again this is what a quadratic
formula looks like so this is what the
squares would look like
and again as you can see if we're only
off by a tiny bit our loss is really
small which means that it's good and if
we're off by a lot then our loss gets
really really big really fast
okay now let's think about the
classification mindset when we're trying
to predict let's say just two different
classes so binary classification
well your output is actually a
probability value which is associated
with how likely it is to be of class a
so
if it's closer to one then class a seems
to be more likely and if it's closer to
zero then it's probably class b
so
in binary cross entropy loss what
happens is you're taking
the real value times the log of the
predicted value and then adding that
with 1 minus the real value times the
log of 1 minus the predicted value
summing that up and using a
normalization factor
you don't really have to know this too
well
this is a little bit you know more
involved mathematically but you just
need to know that loss decreases as the
performance gets better
so one of the metrics of performance
that we can talk about in
classification specifically is accuracy
so let's say that we have a bunch of
pictures here and we want to predict
their labels
so here i also have the actual values so
of course this is an apple this is
orange apple apple etc and use your
imagination think that you know these
two are slightly different from the
original
well let's say that our model is
predicting apple orange orange apple
so you know we got this right we got
this right we got this wrong and we got
this right
so the accuracy of this model is 3 out
of 4 or 75 percent
if you just think about it in english
that makes sense right like
how accurate our model is is how many
predictions it correctly classifies
up until now we've talked about what
goes into our model the features what
comes out of our model you know what
type of prediction it is whether we're
doing classification or regression but
we haven't really talked about the model
itself so let's start talking about the
model
and that brings me to
neural nets okay so the reason why i'm
going to cover neural nets is because
they're very popular and they can also
be used for classification
and regression
now
something that i do have to mention
though is that neural nets have become
sometimes a little bit too popular
and they are being sometimes maybe
overused there are a lot of cases where
you don't need to use a neural net and
if you do use a neural net it's kind of
like using a sledgehammer to crack an
egg it's a little bit you know
too much
there are plenty of other models that
can also do classification and
regression and sometimes
the simpler the model the better and the
reason for that is because you don't
want something that's so good at
predicting your training data set that
you don't that you know it's it's not
good at generalizing and often the thing
with neural nets is that they are very
much a black box the people who create
the neural nets
don't really know what's going on inside
the network itself when you look at some
of these other models when you look at
other types of models in machine
learning oftentimes those might be a
little bit more
transparent than a neural net with a
neural net you just have this network
with a ton of parameters and sometimes
you can't really explain why certain
parameters are higher than others
and so you just the whole question
behind why
is a little bit
lacking sometimes
but with that being said let that be
your warning we're going to talk about
neural nets anyways because
they are a great tool for classification
and for regression
all right let's get started
so as i mentioned you know there are a
ton of different machine learning models
this one here is called the random
forest this one here could just be
classic linear regression this one is
called a support vector machine
and
these different types of models they
have their pros and cons
but we're going to be talking about
neural networks and this is kind of what
a neural net looks like actually this is
exactly what a neural net looks like
you have your inputs they go towards
some layer of neurons and then you have
some sort of output but let's take a
closer look at one of these neurons and
see exactly what's going on
okay so as i just mentioned you have all
of your inputs these are our features
remember how we talked about feature
vectors so this would be a feature
vector with n different features
now
each of these values remember because we
our computer really likes values each of
these values is multiplied by a weight
so that's the first thing that happens
you multiply your input
by some weight
and then
all of these weights go into a neuron
and this neuron basically just sums up
all these weights times the input values
and then you add a little bias to it so
this is just some number that you add in
addition to
the sum product of all of these
and then the output of the sum of all of
these plus the bias goes into an
activation function and an activation
function we'll dive into that a little
bit later but you can think of it as
just some function that will take this
output and alter it a little bit before
we pass it on
and it could be the output but this is
the output of a single neuron
over here
okay and then once you have a bunch of
these neurons all together they form a
neural network which kind of looks
something like this
this is just a cool picture that i found
on wikipedia
all right so let's take a step backwards
and talk about this activation function
because i just kind of glossed over it
and i didn't really tell you
exactly what it is
so
this is what
another this is another example of a
neural net this is what a neural net
would look like you have your inputs
okay they go into these layers and then
you have another layer and then you have
your output layer so the reason why we
have a non-linear activation function
is because if the output of all of these
are linear
then the input you know into this this
would also just be
a sum of some weights plus a bias
what we could do is essentially
propagate these weights into here and
this entire network would just be a
linear regression
i'm not going to do the math here
because
you know it involves a little bit of
some algebra
but if that's something that you're
interested in proving it would be a
really good exercise to prove that if we
don't have a non-linear activation
function then a neural network just
becomes a linear function
which which is bad like that's that's
what we're trying to avoid with the
neural net otherwise we would literally
just use a linear function
without activation functions this
becomes a linear model
okay so these are the kinds of
activation functions that i'm talking
about
there are more than these but these are
three very common ones so here this is a
sigmoid activation function so
it goes from zero to one
tange which goes from negative one to
one
and then relu which is probably one of
the most popular ones
um but basically what happens here is if
a value is greater than zero then it's
just that value and if it's less than
zero then it becomes zero
so basically what happens in your neural
net is after each neuron calculates a
value
it gets altered by one of these
functions so it basically gets projected
into a zero or one a negative one or a
one and then in this case zero or
whatever the output is
and then it goes on to the next neuron
and on and on and on until you finally
reach the output
so that's the point of an activation
function when you put it at the very end
of a neuron it makes the output of the
neuron non-linear and this actually
allows the training to happen we'll talk
about that also in a second
we've seen this picture before how we
have the training set that goes into our
model and then we calculate some loss
and then we make an adjustment
which is called training so let's talk
about this training process now
okay
so this is what our l2 loss function
looks like if you can recall from a few
minutes ago
basically it's a quadratic
function and when your real and
predicted values are further apart
then the difference becomes the diff the
square of the difference
becomes very large right and when
they're close together then you minimize
your loss and all is good in the world
okay
up here the error is really large
and we want to decrease the loss right
like the the smaller the loss the better
our model
is performing in some ways like loss is
just a metric to assess how well our
model is performing
so our goal is to get somewhere down
here
and now up here this is the part that
might involve a little bit of calculus
understanding
but because not everybody out there
knows calculus
i'm going to skip the numbers and just
use diagrams
so if we're up here this is
the opposite of the slope right like the
slope here i mean it's increasing it
would it would be positive but we want
to take
if we want to get down here we want to
go in the opposite direction as that the
higher up we go
the more steep
we want to step right because the
further away we are from our goal
whereas maybe down here we want to take
a baby step over here
because we don't want to overshoot we
don't want to you know pass this and
never be able to find it
so
we use something called gradient descent
in this case and gradient descent is
basically taking
it's measuring to some extent the slope
at a given point and it's taking a step
in the direction that will help us
this is where back propagation comes in
and back propagation is the reason why
neural nets work
so
if we take a look at this l2 loss
function
okay you might think yeah like this
depends on what our y values are right
like what is our predicted value what is
our real value okay well our real value
is staying the same our predicted value
is a function of all the weights that we
just talked about and all the like
inputs right but our inputs are also
kind of staying the same
so
as we adjust the weight values then we
are actually altering this loss function
to some extent
which means that we can calculate the
gradient the slope
of our loss function with respect to the
weights
okay
got that
so
if we're looking at the various weights
in our diagram we might calculate a
slope
that's
you know with respect to that weight
and each of them might be a slightly
different value as we can see here
so what we're going to do with gradient
descent slash back propagation is we're
actually going to set
a new weight for that parameter
and that value is going to be the old
weight plus some alpha
and we'll get back to that but just
think of this as some variable
multiplied by this value going down this
way
a quick side note if you're studying
machine learning some more this might be
a minus sign and this would be the
gradient
but
for all purposes right now
because we're using these arrows instead
it's more intuitive to just add
something in this direction
if that confused you
you can ignore it until you start
getting into the math of back
propagation
but what i'm trying to say is that
essentially calculating this gradient
with respect to one of the weights in
the neural network
allows us to take a step
in that direction in order to
create a new weight
and this value alpha here this is called
our learning rate because we don't want
to take this massive step every single
time because then we're making a huge
change to our neural network instead we
want to take baby steps and if every
single baby step is telling us to go in
one direction then okay fine we're going
that direction
but taking small steps is better than
you know overshooting and
diverging off into the land of
infinities
yeah
um
you can think of this as for example if
you were tailoring something it's better
to remove
like bits and bits of the fabric rather
than removing an entire chunk and
realizing oh my gosh i just took off way
too much
so that's what the learning rate is for
it's so that we don't you know take off
a huge chunk of the fabric instead we go
bit by bit by bit
okay
so then going back to all these other
weights
we can see how each weight in the neural
net is getting updated with respect to
what this gradient value
is telling us
so basically this is how training
happens in a neural net we calculate out
the loss okay we see there's a massive
loss we can calculate the gradient
of that loss function with respect to
each of the weight parameters in the
neural network and now this allows us to
have some direction
some measure of the direction that we
want to travel in for that weight
whether we want to increase the weight
or decrease the weight
we know based on this gradient that you
know we're finding
so that is how back propagation works
and that's exactly what's happening in
this step right here
that is our crash course on neural
networks it is not the most
comprehensive crash course out there if
you are interested in neural networks i
do recommend diving in deeper into the
mathematics of it which i'm not going to
cover in this class because not
everybody has had the mathematical
prerequisites
but
again if that's something you're
interested definitely go and check it
out let's move on to talk about how we
would actually implement this neural net
in code if we wanted to create a neural
net
so this is where machine learning
libraries come in
okay so in machine learning we often
need to implement a model
we probably always need to implement a
model
and if we want our model to be a neural
net like this
okay that's great we could go and we
could code you know each
neuron or we could code a neuron class
and we could stitch them all together
but
we don't really want to start from
scratch that would be a lot of work when
we could be using that time to fine-tune
our network itself
so instead we want to use libraries that
have already been developed and
optimized to help us train these models
so if we use a library called tensorflow
then our neural net could look something
just like this and that's a lot easier
than trying to go through and
you know develop and optimize the
network entirely from scratch ourselves
so straight from the website tensorflow
is an open source library that helps you
develop and train ml models
okay great that sounds like exactly what
we want so tensorflow is a library
that's comprised of many modules that
you know you might be able to see here
but for example we might have
this data module and here
you know we have a bunch of tools that
help us import data and keep data
consistent and usable with the models
that we will create
another great part of this api is keras
so here we actually have a bunch of the
different modules which will help us
you know create models
help us optimize them
and these are different types of
optimizers
et cetera so basically the whole point
of this is that you know we want to use
these packages we want to use these
libraries because they help us
maximize our efficiency where we can
focus on training our models and they're
also just you know really good and like
fine-tuned already so why would we want
to waste our time
to code stuff from scratch
all right so now let's move over to our
notebook and i'm going to show you guys
how to actually implement a neural net
using tensorflow just you know
straightforward
feed forward no pun intended neural
network
now that we've learned a little bit
about neural nets about tensorflow let's
try to actually implement a neural net
using tensorflow so
let me go back to this collab tab and
let's actually
create a new notebook
okay and this notebook again i'm going
to call this maybe just a feed forward
nullnet example
all right now i'm going to again use
these same imports
run this
great
it's running
okay so now the second thing that i'm
going to have to import in here
is my data set and so here i have a data
set called diabetes.csv which is also
in the description below
click ok there and that was a that was a
substantially smaller data set than the
one that we tried to import at the
beginning which don't worry we will get
back to at the very end of this video
but that's why it took significantly
shorter to upload all right so
this data set that we're using here in
diabetes.csv this is a data set that was
originally from the national institute
of diabetes and digestive and kidney
diseases
and in this data set all these patients
are females at least 21 years old
of pima indian heritage
and this data set has a bunch of
different features but the final feature
is whether or not the patient has
diabetes
okay
let's take a look at this data set
so the first thing that we can do is
once again create a data frame
so we're going to use read csv again and
here we can just say diabetes.csv
let's see what this looks like
all right so we can see that each of
these is one patient
and how many pregnancies they've had
their glucose blood pressure skin
thickness
etc a bunch of other measurements
okay so it's always a good idea to do
some sort of data visualization on
these values in order to see if any of
these you know have some sort of
correlation to the outcome and there are
many different metrics that you can run
you can try to literally find the
correlation between pregnancies and the
outcome but for this purpose i think
it's a lot easier to visualize things
in i guess a visual way
how else would you visualize things
so here what i'm going to do is i'm
going to
plot each of these as a histogram so
each value in the feature as a histogram
and then compare it
to the outcome so
let's try to do that using a for loop so
for i in range
and here i'm going to use the columns
of the data frame
um up until the very last one because
that's the outcome that's the one that
we're actually comparing against
what i'm going to do is say the label is
equal to
dataframe.columns
i and actually
let me make this screen larger for you
guys because i know that some people
yeah okay hopefully you can see this a
little bit better
so
anyways down here uh for i in this range
okay how about this this is better
okay so for each
basically this for loop here is trying
to run through all of these columns
except for the last one
and the label is basically just getting
the data frame column at that index so
to show you guys what that actually
looks like
let's run df.columns
so again this is just it's similar to
going through a list of these items
okay so the label we're you know
indexing into something in this list and
what we're going to do is
plot the histogram
so we can index into a data frame by
calling the data frame and then saying
you know where the data frame
outcome
is equal to one which means that they do
have diabetes
and then
so this basically creates another
let me show you
this basically is a data frame where all
the outcomes are equal to one
okay cool so this is our new data frame
where all the outcomes are one which
means that all these patients are
diabetes positive
and then
we're just going to index into the label
that we have right here so we're just
indexing it to the column
and
what i'm actually going to do is the
same thing now but instead of one make
this zero so now this here
let me show this to you guys again
this here is
a data frame where all the outcomes are
zero
so that means that everybody here is
um
so that means everybody here is diabetes
negative
okay perfect
well we want to tell the difference
between the two so i'm also going to
assign these colors so here let's use
blue
and red
and then of course a label so this is
no diabetes
and this up here
diabetes
all right
so plt
now let's give this a title let's just
use you know the name of the label
and then the y label
is n
and the x label
is
the label
if we call plt.legend
like this then this actually shows us
the legend including these labels
and at the very end we call plt.show in
order to see the plot
so let's run this
all right
basically for each of
the values
we are plotting
the measurements here and it's kind of
hard to see
you know diabetes versus no diabetes so
another trick that we can do here is we
can say alpha equals 0.7
if we run these again you'll see that it
makes them a little bit easier to see
behind one another
okay so something else that we might
want if we take a look at
the number of values so if we say the
length of this versus the length of
this so this is saying how many patients
are diabetes positive and how many are
diabetes negative
we see that we actually have two
different values one of them is only 268
positive patients and then 500 negative
patients
so what we actually want to do is
normalize this which means that we want
to compare these histogram distributions
to how many actual
values there are in that data set
otherwise you know you can clearly see
that
there are more no diabetes patients here
than diabetes patients and this isn't
really a fair
measurement
so i'm going to say density here equals
true and just for kicks i'm going to say
the number of bins that we're going to
use in our histogram is 15.
then here
we would say this is probability because
we're normalizing now using the density
which means basically that we're just
taking each of these values and dividing
it by how many total values there are in
the data set so instead it's a ratio
for each column rather than just a
straightforward number
okay click enter again and now here we
have
more of a visualization
so it does seem like you know people who
have diabetes might have more
pregnancies
or people you know higher glucose levels
that makes sense right
seems like maybe slightly higher blood
pressure but that's pretty inconclusive
maybe skin thickness a little bit but
also you know insulin a little bit
inconclusive it does seem like perhaps
people who have diabetes have a slightly
higher bmi
but so on so you can see that like
there's no these values aren't separable
which means that we can't really tell
based on one
value
whether or not somebody has diabetes or
not and this is where the power of
machine learning comes into play is that
we can actually learn
whether or not or predict whether or not
somebody has diabetes or not based on
all of these features all together
okay
so
now that we have this what we're going
to do is split this into our x and y
values so
recall that the x is a matrix right
so here i'm going to say it's just going
to be all the columns up until the last
value
got values
so let's run that and let's see oops
and what does this give us this gives us
now an array this is now a numpy array
okay and we're going to do the same
thing with y
except y is just a single column so we
can do this
and i missed the s again
okay so if we see why
it's a huge array but it's one
dimensional as you can see and it's just
all the different labels in the data set
so now we have our x and our y values we
can actually just go ahead and split
this up into our test and our our
training in our test data sets
so
something that i'm going to import is
from sklearn
so this package this function here
allows us to split arrays or matrices
into random train and test
subsets which you know is very useful
so all we have to do is plug in our
arrays and it should help us you know we
would dictate the
test size and the train size and then it
would help us split them up
so what i'm going to do is say x train
and x i'm going to call this temp
y train
and y temp
equal
oh we have to import this so actually
i'm going to come back up here
and say from sklearn.model
selection
import this
okay so make sure you rerun that cell
but now we have access to that function
so here train test split
and i'm going to pass in my x and my y
arrays
and then i'm going to say the test size
is equal to
let's use 60 of our data for training
and
20 for validation and twenty percent for
test so what i'm going to do first is
just split this up into zero point four
and
i'm just going to pass in random state
equals zero so this allows us to get the
same split every single time
now the reason why i want to do this
again but use 0.5 is now with this
temporary
data set which is technically you know
the test set
we're going to split this now into the
validation and the test so let's do x
valid
test
and instead of x and y we're going to
pass in the temp that we just created up
here so this is essentially x and y but
only 40 of that data set and now we're
breaking this down further
into 50 50 which is going to be our test
our validation and test data sets so
let's run this cool checks out
and let's build our model
so here i'm going to say model equals tf
which is tensorflow
keras which is part of tensorflow that
helps us write you know some neural nets
and stuff like that
called tf dot keras
so let's check that out okay tf keras so
basically it's this uh api
that allows us to easily build some
neural net models
and here we're going to call the
sequential
so let's see
basically it
groups a linear stack of layers into a
model which is exactly what we want
because our neural net is
uh
because our neural net is exactly a
stack of layers
so let's pass in some fears here
okay
i think how i'm going to architect this
is i'm just going to use a very simple
model so keras
dot layers dot dense
16 okay so basically what this actually
let me
activation equals
okay what this is like setting up here
is
this is a layer of dense neural nets
what does dense mean it just means that
it takes input from everything and it
outputs
a value but densely connected is just
you know okay it's a layer that's deeply
connected with its preceding layer
so it just means that every single
like neuron here
is receiving input from every single
neuron
that it sees from the past
all right going back to here
um this just means that this is a layer
of 16 neurons that are densely connected
so if we go back to here it means that
this layer here is comprised of 16
different neurons
and then our activation function is relu
which is one of the activation functions
that we saw previously
where
if x is
less than zero
then this becomes zero i guess less than
or equal to zero this becomes zero and
if x is greater than zero then
this becomes just x
okay
and you know i'm just going to add
another layer in there just for kicks
and then finally we're going to conclude
this with a
layer of only one node
but instead this layer is only going to
have one node and the activation here
is going to be sigmoid
and what that helps us do is this is
this is where the binary classification
comes in because sigmoid if you can
remember maps to zero or one so
the
the point of this activation function is
that it maps
our input to a probability of whether or
not you know something belongs to a
single class
so
this is our neural net it was really
that easy we can click enter
or shift enter and then now let's
compile this model so we can call
model.compile
and we're going to need a few different
things here so the first one is going to
be our optimizer
so you can see here that our there are a
bunch of different
optimizers that tensorflow already has
for us
now
which one do you choose that's kind of
that's that's a hard question to answer
because it's a question that people
still don't really know the answer to
but one of the most commonly used
optimizers is atom so that's where we're
going to start
so going back to our example here let's
do optimizer
and let's set this equal to
dot
tensorflow.paris.org
dot
atom
and we're going to set our hyper
parameter called the learning rate
we're going to let's start off with what
the default is so 0.001
now the second thing that we have to do
is define our loss function so
our loss is equal to tf.cara's
dot losses so now because we're doing
binary classification the one that we're
going to use is called binary cross
entropy so binary
cross entropy like this
and
then the final thing that we're going to
do is add
a metric for accuracy
and the reason why we're doing that is
because we want to know you know how
many do we actually
get right
so enter
we now have a compiled model we have a
neural net that we can actually feed
data to and we can train
but before we do that let's actually see
how well this might perform on you know
our training data and our validation
data
what we're going to call is model dot
evaluate
and here let's pass in x train and y
train
and see what happens
okay
so
here we're getting a loss of 16 and an
accuracy of
0.35 which is around like 35 so that
that's pretty bad
what about instead of train let's do
validation
okay it's around the same a loss of 11
and accuracy of 35
all right this is because our model
hasn't seen our train or validation set
yet and that's why the accuracy is so
low we haven't really done any training
so let's see if we can fix that
what we're going to do is call model.fit
and pass in the x train and the y frame
values
pass in something called the batch size
and then epochs is how many times how
many iterations through the entire data
set we're going to train this
and pass in the validation data
now this validation data is just so that
after every single epoch we can measure
what the validation loss and the
validation accuracy is
so x valid y valid
now we can run that
all right so you can see that our neural
net is training now going back really
quickly to this batch size
batch size is just a term that refers to
the number of
like samples or training examples in
this case it's the number of women that
we have like samples from
that is used in every single iteration
so this is how many samples we see
before we go back and we make a weights
update
so you can see that here look our loss
in our training set
is decreasing fairly successfully
and our inc our accuracy
okay our accuracy seems to be increasing
great
now what about our validation loss okay
our validation loss seems to be
decreasing decreasing decreasing a
little bit of an increase at the end but
that's that's a good sign
and our validation accuracy seems to be
also increasing
well let's see if we can do better so
a few problems with our current data set
we see that look all of our values here
i mean our insulin our insulin range is
from zero all the way out to like 800
whereas something else might be
on the scale of
like
you know skin thickness is on scale of 0
to 100 but
uh
bmi is on the scale of 0 to like 2.5
the fact that our features are so
different in terms of their range that
is something that could be messing up
our results so instead what we're going
to do is we're actually going to scale
the results so all of them are
on a more standardized range
the first thing that i'm going to do is
i'm going to
import a package that lets us scale
so
just like how we imported this function
up here i'm going to
import from sklearn
pre-processing
i'm going to import standard scalar
okay let's rerun this again
and let's go back down to
down here like before we split it up
into the train and test sets
okay
so here let's just run this again for
good measure but instead of splitting it
up right here what i'm going to do is
i'm going to scale the quantities so
here i can define a scalar
and set this equal to standard scalar
and i'm going to say okay this scalar
let's fit and then transform
this x matrix
all right
so once we've done that our new data i'm
actually so let's actually see what what
x looks like now
so we can see that everything is a lot
closer in range it goes you know from
maybe around
like one to like negative one okay let's
actually see let's plot these values
again and see what exactly is going on
here so
here let's transform this back into a
data frame so what i can do is say
transformed
data frame equals
pandas.dataframe so this is creating a
data frame
and then
here okay let's let's use a placeholder
called data and then the columns are the
same as our current columns
now this data we're actually going to do
something called a horizontal stack
which means that we're taking our x our
new
transformed variable x
along with
this y
but
we have to do a little bit of reshaping
here so we're going to call
numpy.reshape because right now our x is
a two-dimensional matrix but y is only a
one-dimensional matrix
which means that let me just show you
real fast so x dot shape if we
see what this is and then compare this
to y dot shape
see this is a two dimensional variable
and this is only one dimensional it
doesn't have a one here which means that
it's not
you know a 768 by one matrix it's just
it's just a vector of length 768
and if we call
a horizontal stack of the two
there'll be um there's going to be an
error
so instead we're going to reshape this
and this just means okay
project it into something where negative
one means like numpy gets to decide
this one just means in that second
dimension it'll be comma one so here
it's going to return an object of 768
comma one
all right
so let's run this
oops here columns
cool
and then instead of data frame dot
columns
actually all of these we can leave the
same but here we just want to make sure
that we're plotting the transformed data
frame
so if we can see now
like most of these so what standard
scalar is doing is it's actually mapping
our values to a normal distribution and
trying to calculate
like how far off our values are from the
norm
so here
you know we can see that glucose levels
now range
i mean it looks like it's fairly
centered around zero or negative one
um
but all of these are now normalized
okay so we can actually delete the cell
now that we've visualized it we don't
need it
and what we're going to do is we are
going to
[Music]
uh
this is now our new x and we can
directly pass that down into here but
one other thing that i had mentioned
is remember how
if we take x and we say x
for the outcome
is equal to one
or sorry i shouldn't say x i should say
the data frame or the transform data
frame
doesn't matter
and then if i set this equal to zero
remember how these two
sorry a little typo
remember how these two values are so
different like the number of
non-diabetes patients is almost double
the number of diabetes positive patients
so this can sometimes also
lead to
the neural net not training so well
instead what we're going to do is we're
actually going to
try to get these two to be approximately
equal
and we can do that with another thing
called
random over sampler which means that
we're essentially trying to
get
like more random samples into that first
sample so that they now balance out
these two values balance out the lengths
now okay we can do this by importing
another package
so we're going to use a package called
imbalance learn
dot over sampling
and we're going to import random over
sampler
now watch what happens
oh
okay that did not give me an error but
in the past this might give you an error
and if it does what you're going to do
is just come up here and type in
uh an exclamation mark pip
install dash u
imbalanced
run that and then this if there's an
error here that says you know there's no
library then this
up here will solve that for you
and yeah you you would have to restart
the runtime but because
this worked i'm not going to do that
all right let's come back down here so
right before we're splitting it into the
test and train sets
over here let's actually
use this random over sampler in order to
get both of these
uh equal to one so here let's call
random
over sampler
and then let's split x and y
well i guess let's let's redo this x and
y definition by calling fit resample
and then x comma y
then
we run this cell
all right
uh we can't exactly
we we never like rerand
we can do this again
all right so now we see that we have 500
where the outcome is one and 500 where
the outcome is zero so this is a good
sign this means that now our data set is
balanced in terms of the outcomes
let's
rerun all of these
okay so it seems like our accuracy is
closer to 50 now
and let's think about like intuitively
why that's happening well okay let's say
that the first result it's just
predicting random numbers zero one zero
one zero one okay but
our data set
naturally before it had more
values that were
uh negative than positive and so
naturally that accuracy would be skewed
towards something closer to 30 percent
if for example it's like a one to two
ratio
because just because of the fact that we
didn't have very many values that
were equal that were diabetes positive
but now because we've balanced it this
value is much closer to 50.
all right
now let's try to train our model once
again
okay so we see that again this loss is
decreasing this is good and our accuracy
seems to be increasing which is also
good
and let's check our validation because
remember we need to see how this would
generalize to unseen data
our validation loss great seems to be
decreasing validation accuracy
seems to be increasing and now our
validation accuracy is somewhere closer
to
77
which is a significant improvement
all right now at the very very end what
we're going to do is we're going to
evaluate this model
on our test data set
and we can see that okay our loss is
around 0.5 but that doesn't really mean
anything to us
but our accuracy is around 77.5
which is pretty good because we've never
seen this data before
so that's a quick tutorial on how we
just used tensorflow to create a neural
net and then use that neural net to
predict whether or not the sample of
uh pima indian
descent women have diabetes or not based
on you know some data that we were given
so that's very very cool now
for the other tutorial that we started
off with we will get to that in one
second but first i wanted to talk about
some more advanced neural network
architectures
let's talk about recurrent neural
networks
we've already seen the feed forward
neural net we've already you know done
an example problem with it we're very
familiar with it right you have your
inputs and then they feed into you know
the hidden layers and then you get your
outputs okay cool yeah we've got that
you guys have got that
but what if this data over here our
inputs
were some sort of series or sequence so
for example they might be stock prices
from the past 20 days or they might be
values that represent different words in
a sentence where the sentence has some
sort of you know
sequence to it or it might be
temperatures from the past 10 months
so on you you get what i mean like just
basically if this was some sort of
sequence if this data were a sequence a
feed-forward neural net would not do a
really good job at picking that up
why because all of these different
layers it evaluates each value as if
they were independent so even if there
were a series
it's it's a lot harder for our feed for
our neural net to pick up on that
that's where recurrent neural networks
come in so basically here we have our
data points
and you know this is our data point
taken at t0 at t1 at t2 so we're going
through time
and what we can do is we can feed these
into a layer of weights
and then these layer of weights may or
may not produce some sort of output
but basically what this is doing because
the
you know calculation at each point takes
into account the previous
calculations as we move through this
network we're essentially creating some
sort of memory with the neural net so
this neural net at whenever you know
when we feed in x2 so x at t2
we actually have some information that
we remember about x at t 0 and x at t
so that makes a recurrent neural net
very powerful
ta-da this part acts as a memory
and now instead of just straightforward
back prop we have to use something
called back propagation through time in
order to adjust these weights
okay this is our unfolded rnn
and this is what our folded version
would look like so
you see how you know our x at time t is
just fed into this neuron which outputs
some
value at time t
and this value kind of gets cycled into
the next iteration of x and so on
well there are a few problems right with
this because
this rnn if you if you imagine there are
many many time steps this might end up
being a really deep network
and then two
during back propagation we might be
seeing the same terms like the weights
in here
over and over and over because of the
recurrent nature of this rnn
now why are those problems
well these two kind of compound on each
other and you might get something called
exploding gradients where the model can
become really unstable and then
incapable of learning
because all the gradients that we're
using in back propagation are getting
bigger and bigger and bigger until
they've reached like infinity
and then
you know our model
our model updates become literally all
over the place and we can't really
control our weights and then yeah
not good stuff happens
on the other hand there's also such
thing as vanishing gradients so here our
gradients get closer and closer and
closer to zero and so at this point our
model stops updating and then it becomes
also incapable of learning
so some really smart people have studied
these problems and they've decided okay
here are some different ways that we can
overcome this problem
there are a few things that you can do
with the activation function but i'll
let you look that up on your own time
instead i'm going to talk about
different sorts of cells or neurons that
people have come up with in order to
combat this
so there's such thing as the great the
sorry the gated recurrent unit
and this unit as you can see so it still
takes x at time t as an input but here
just has a bunch of gates that are
associated with it and then it has some
sort of output so there's just more
parameters inside the neuron itself
rather than trying to just directly sum
up some weights
there's also the long short term memory
unit which looks something like this
it's very very similar to the unit that
we just saw but instead of two gates it
has three again i'm not going to dive
too deep into these things because these
are more advanced topics but i just
wanted you guys to be aware that these
exist and if we do use them an example
this is exactly what's going on it's
just we have a few more
you know bells and whistles inside of
our neuron all right so now that we've
touched upon some of the more
theoretical aspects of neural nets and
machine learning
let's walk through a different
tensorflow example with text
classification
and try to see if we can classify some
wine reviews
so let's get started on that let's go
back to our co-lab notebook where we
were studying the wine reviews and let's
continue on with that so here i have
that notebook open this is the code that
we typed at the very beginning of this
class
so here we have our wine reviews and
we're actually actually need to restart
um we need to rerun some cells
and we need to re-import our data so let
me do that over here
okay so we see that it's imported
let's rerun everything
all right
cool
okay this is this is our uh these are
our points is what we're trying to
classify now let's split this up into a
low tier and height here as we were
saying earlier so how we can do that is
if we type in
quality label let's say
so let's come up with a new label or
actually let's just say this is the
label
and we say this will be if df dot points
so basically the points column of the
data frame if it's greater than or equal
to 90.
let's uh
this basically will return a boolean so
either every single row
it will be false if it's less than 90 or
true if it's greater than 90. and
all i'm going to do at the very end here
is
forces as a type for an integer so that
it gets mapped to zero or one because
remember our computer understands
numbers really well
so here then i'm going to say that the
data frame i don't need all the columns
i know which ones i'm going to use so
i'm just going to say it'll be the
description
and the label
so remember this is the description
and this is the label okay and you know
what let me just add points in here
anyways
so now if i look at the very beginning
of this
okay so we have the points and we have
the label let's look at the tail
maybe that'll be okay so here again we
have the points they're equal to 90 and
then the label
all right great
so
let's now split this up into the
training validation and test data sets
so
i wanted to this there just to show you
guys that you know we were mapping this
the right thing but this is what we can
actually
um keep now that we have our data frame
i want to split this up into our
training validation and test data frames
now we did this in a slightly different
way before but i'm going to show you a
different way to do it because i want
you to realize that there's not just one
way to do it like whenever you're
working with a data set you want to be
able to be flexible
and split things up in different ways
so here i'm going to say train val test
i'm going to set this equal to np so
numpy dot split which is going to split
our data frame
and this is the data frame that we're
going to split and actually what i'm
going to do is i'm going to mix things
up a little bit so i'm going to say
sample
and i'm going to sample all of them
which is going to basically draw random
samples but sampling the entire data
frame
and then i'm going to pass in the
different
cuts where i actually want there to be
breaks in the data frame
so what that's going to look like is i
want it to be 60 for the training 20 for
the validation 20 for the test and
actually in a data frame this size you
could even go like 80 for training 10
for validation 10 for test
and the reason is just because there's
so much data that like
even with your validation and test sets
even if you're using only 10 that's
still enough data to kind of see how it
generalizes
so actually that's what i'm going to do
um so i'm going to map this to an
integer and i'm going to say okay so 0.8
will be our first cut meaning 80 will go
towards the train data set
so i'm going to say 0.8 times the length
of this data frame
and then our second cut is going to be
at the 90 mark which means that 10 of
the data set will be for the validation
here and 10 the remaining 10 will be for
test
so if we run that okay cool
and we can quickly say like you know
let's print the length of these
great so you can see still plenty of
samples for our validation and tests
data sets
all right so this next function i'm
actually going to copy from this
tensorflow module right here
all right so we're going to use this
we're going to slightly edit it and
basically what this function does is it
converts each training validation and
test set data frame into a
tf.data.dataset object and then it will
shuffle and batch the data so
let's copy this code and go back to ours
right here now i'm going to make a
slight difference because our data set
is so big i'm actually going to change
this to a larger batch size and then
down here instead of using batch size
i'm going to do tf.data.autotune
okay great so let's run this except
actually so
in this data set i believe they use
target to define
their uh target column
okay yeah so they use target to create
their target variable but for us we
already have a column that defines it
and we've called it the label so instead
what we're going to do is we're going to
change this to label
okay and then the next thing that we're
going to do
is instead of this part here
with all of this we're just going to set
the data frame equal to data dot
description
because that's the only part of the data
frame that we actually care about
alrighty
and here we can because we change that
we can remove this
and if we run that this should be able
to successfully create our train data
our validation data and our test data so
here i can do train data equals
df
to data set
and i'm going to run this on the train
and actually let's just copy and paste
this a few more times and here instead
of train
this will be valid
and here i will call this test and
actually we didn't create a valid it's
val
now run this hopefully great there are
no errors
so basically what this um function is
doing it's shuffling our data for us and
it's formatting it in a proper you know
format but then it's also batching it
into our batch size that we specified
and pre-fetching now this prefetch you
can kind of um
i guess
you can think about it as
just try to speed things up a little bit
trying to optimize things a little bit
so this it just reduces some friction
so these are our data sets now let's try
to take a look at like what's actually
in here so something that we can do is
called train data of zero but actually
this train data is now going to be like
a tensorflow data set so what you need
to do is you actually need to convert it
quickly so that we can see what's going
on
so you'll see that this is actually a
tensor
it's i guess it's a tuple in this case
but you have the tensor of all the
strings and then you also have the
corresponding labels that are associated
with them the zeros and ones that we
came up with
all right
great so let's talk about how our model
is now going to work one thing that we
imported that you might have noticed up
here was this tensorflow hub
so what tensorflow hub is
is tensorflow hub is a repository of
trained machine learning models so
basically these are models that are
ready to use um
they just need some fine tuning and we
can actually use one of these to help us
in our process of text classification
so recall that computers don't really
understand text that well right like
computers understand numbers really well
so
we actually need a way to
transform
all of these sentences like this into
like
numbers that our computer can understand
and that's where
this embedding comes into play
so
one embedding that we will actually use
is
this nnlm
this en english and then dimension 50.
so this is token based text embedding
trained on english google news
using like a seven billion
document corpus
so it's a saved model that they already
have for text embedding
and let's see how we do so
you can say embedding equals
set that and actually you know what
let's just label this
okay
so here is our embedding then we're
going to create a variable called hub
layer and set this equal to hub dot
keras layer
and this is uh you want to pass in the
embedding link
and the data type that we're actually
going to use we're going to
tell this that we're using strings
and then finally we are going to tell
this that you know trainable is true
okay cool
oops
we can actually call this hub layer
and we can do that by passing in
let's uh you know do this little hack
again train data
and
um
just say zero
oops okay so basically what we did we
need to only pass the strings
so basically what we've done here is
every single
uh sentence that we had in our data set
we're essentially projecting it into
a
length of 50
vector containing only numbers so that's
what our embedding did it basically
transformed our text into this vector of
numbers
that now our model can go and understand
so let's build our model
so let's again calls keras sequential so
previously what we did was we passed in
you know a list of all the different
layers but
i'm just going to show you guys another
way that you can build a model so here
you can also do model.add
and the first thing that we're going to
add is this hub layer that we
defined up here
so basically now the first
transformation will be this text to
value numerical value transformation
then what i'm going to do
is i'm going to add a layer
and this is just going to be a classic
dense layer
and let's use 16 neurons again
and we're going to use relu and i'm just
going to add another layer of those and
then finally i'm going to add
my uh
final output just like in the previous
neural net that we created in our feed
forward neural net
okay so now that we have our model i'm
going to actually compile it with the
same exact compilation statement as the
previous model the feed forward network
that we did so let me just paste that in
here
so i'm saying model.compile i'm using
atom as the optimizer again and actually
the slanting rate let's go back to 0.001
um i'd copy that from another example
and then for the loss we're again going
to use binary cross entropy and for our
metric we're going to add accuracy now
these are because we're doing binary
classification
okay so here first let's actually
so now that we have our model and it's
compiled
let's try to evaluate the untrained
model on the train data
and let's actually do the same thing for
the validation data
okay so it seems like our accuracy is
around 40 percent
not so great our loss may be around 0.7
okay so
let's see what will happen if we
do model.fit
so here let's pass in our trained data
and let's also
let's do uh
10 epochs and let's pass in our
validation
data
okay
now we're starting to train
okay so our accuracy is increasing it's
over 50 now this is a good sign and our
loss seems to be decreasing so this
means that our model is training
cool it's still increasing we like to
see it
and it's still going
okay so i'm gonna let you guys train
your model you can pause the video
really quickly but
i'll be back once our models are done
training
okay so our model's finished training
let's take a look at the results
so
here it seems like our loss is steadily
decreasing which is a good sign
and our accuracy seems to be increasing
almost to 90
okay that's also a really good sign now
if we go over here and look at the
validation loss in the accuracy our
validation loss okay it starts pretty
high and then it decreases and then it
seems like it starts to go back up again
which means that
seems like as training's going on the
validation performance is actually worse
and worse and if we look at the accuracy
okay it starts off pretty decent at 80
and it gets better and then it starts to
kind of plateau and then it dips a
little bit
okay so what's going on here
this is a classic example of overfitting
so overfitting means that the training
data that you do see that your model
sees
the model learns how to predict the
training data really well but then it
generalizes really poorly so what we can
actually do is we can plot
the model history so
if we do history.history
what happened
and we look at the accuracy
and then we also do the validation
accuracy
okay just some labels here
and what we can
alright and then let's just give this a
title
and then
labeling
what is going on here
and then at the very end we can do
guilty
so this is going to plot
our accuracy hopefully
oh i think we have to type out accuracy
okay so we can see that our training
accuracy starts here and it gets better
and better and better whereas our
validation accuracy seems to okay it
does well and then it kind of tapers off
now if we look at the loss it's a
different story so here
let's just change this plot a little bit
and let's look at this again okay so it
looks like our training loss actually
decreases very well
whereas our validation loss seems to
decrease and then start to go up again
so
basically our model is incapable of
generalizing because we've trained it so
much on our
data that we're feeding it
so how do we fix this
one way would be to add something called
drop out
and drop out just means that every once
in a while you select a few nodes that
aren't really
working
so
if i do this
i can add a few layers like this in here
and that should actually improve my
training
so the reason why this works is that
every single time the model has to
basically
go through these obstacles these dropout
layers where some nodes aren't working
and try to figure out how to work around
that
so
that helps it generalize a little bit
we're just adding a little bit of
randomness in there
all right so here let's uh you know
repeat our hub layer
compile our model
evaluate okay it seems like this is
already really high
but
that's fine it could just be the
opposite of what we just did
um
all right and then also another thing to
do is stop earlier so let's just use
five epochs
all right i'll see you guys after
training
all right so we're back let's take a
look at our results so our loss is
decreasing accuracy increasing great
okay so our accuracy our loss seems to
increase a tiny bit by the end and our
accuracy seems to decrease a tiny bit by
the end but this is probably a much
better generalizable model than our
previous one that we had trained
so
finally what we can do is we can
evaluate this
on our test data in order to get our
final results
so sweet look at that our loss seems to
be around 0.38 and our accuracy is
around 83 percent so that seems to be
really good
awesome
all right so up until this point we just
created a
neural network that we saw would help us
with text classification
however we did use part of the
tensorflow hub which you know is not a
bad thing but if we wanted more
control over
this model what would we have to do and
so i'm just going to show you guys
really quickly how we would recreate
this model using a lstm
here i'm going to label this section
lstm
and the first thing that we're going to
do is to create some sort of encoder for
our text because once again
our computer does not understand english
so
what i'm going to do is create an
encoder
and set this equal to tf.layers.txt
vectorization
and then here i'm going to say the max
tokens well this is going to be the
maximum number of words that we're going
to remember
and i'm going to set this to 2000
so then what i'm going to do is call
encoder.adapt
and here i'm going to pass in
uh our train data
and then actually because our train data
doesn't really
like this encoder would only need the
sentences
uh we're just going to also pass in a
quick little lambda function because
our train data is composed of the text
and the label but we don't really care
about the label we just want the text
so let's run this
okay
and let's check out our vocab
so we can call encoder.getvocabulary
and then let's actually uh let's take a
look at this let's see like the first 20
items
all right so here these are words that
are encoded in our encoder or part of
the vocabulary and this here this this
represents any unknown tokens
okay then we can create our model
and again it doesn't really matter which
way you define it but
this is how i'm going to define it this
time
and the first thing that we're going to
pass in is the encoder because this is
the encoder is what is going to
basically vectorize our text
and then we need to have some sort of
embedding for this vectorized text
and that we are going to call
keras.layer
dot embedding
so for the embedding we're going to need
to pass in an input dimension and i'm
going to set this equal to the length of
the encoder's vocabulary
and then we also need to pass in an
output dimension
so this output dimension i'm just going
to set equal to 32 because i think
that's how many lstm
um
that will be the size of our lstm
and then
i will also
set mask 0
equal to true and the reason why we use
this masking is so that we can handle
variable sequence lengths
okay so that's our embedding layer so
basically this turns these two together
we'll be able to turn our sentence into
a vector of numbers that our neural net
will be able to comprehend
then next i'm going to add in a
lstm layer and it's literally as easy as
this
um and we just you know how many nodes
there are i put the output dimensions 32
so that's the value that i'm going to
pass here
and then let's just add a dense layer
let's do a drop out layer because you
know we saw previously that we might be
prone to over training
and then finally we
result with a
dense
layer
sorry i totally typed these wrong drop
dropout and then dense one
i also forgot the activation so here we
want sigmoid because this is the output
and up here we want
really
okay so this is our model
and
here i missed another s
cool
all right
now for the compilation let's just
borrow this right here
and again we want to evaluate this
on our trade
data
as well as our validation data
just to see you know what happens
so let's take a look at that
okay so our accuracy seems to be around
53
not great our loss around 0.7
okay
so
now let's
train our model
let's try five to see what happens
well
i will see you guys in a bit
all right so now we're nearing uh the
end of the training
and let's just take a quick look at the
results so here our loss for our
training data is decreasing strictly and
our accuracy seems to be strictly
increasing
now let's talk about the validation law
so it does seem like you know we cut it
off early enough that this is still
decreasing and waivers a little bit
and our validation accuracy seems to be
i mean the overall trend seems to be
improving okay so we have 84 accuracy
here which is pretty good
and finally at the end of course we can
evaluate our model once again so here
it's called model.evaluate and use our
test data to see what happens
all right cool so we get an accuracy on
our test data of 84
which is pretty sweet
that is the end of the jupiter notebook
tutorial
and
thank you guys you know for being here
for following along with this
and now you've learned how to
i mean not only implement a feed forward
neural network with numerical data but
you've also learned to use tensorflow
with text classification and trying to
figure out whether or not a wine review
based on the review itself
is maybe you know lower tier or higher
tier which
is awesome
i hope you guys enjoyed this tutorial
and you know give this video a thumbs up
if you liked it leave a comment and
don't forget to subscribe to free code
camp and kylie
all right see you guys next time